[Music]
meet the residents of element City
Air usually has their head in the cloud
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy
nothing weird going on here uh just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
[Music]
and fire as ordered we run a little hot
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
it cannot mix
pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix
plus my dad would boil you alive why
doesn't anyone get to tell you what you
can do in your life
on
why do they even have these who knows
[Music]
remember I see a change in you
what her guy you live here it's my mom's
place we got two kids that are swimming
around here somewhere
[Music]
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes I never once asked what I wanted
to do
try this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
you see he likes it